avec 114 millions d'euros inscrits au
budget 2010 uytsel les routes et les
transports représentent le plus
important poste de dépenses en matière
d'investissement pour le département des
yvelines
car en marge de l'entretien de près de
1600 km de route il faut également
penser à l'avenir est donc modifié
certains équipements en fonction des
besoins des usagers
exemple ici avec l'aménagement et
l'élargissement de la rd 30 à plaisir
lancer en 2015 entre création de
giratoires et construction de ponts ou
encore ici entre montesson et
sartrouville avec la réalisation de
voies nouvelles
mais routes départementales sont
complètement saturé dans cette région
notamment en centre urbain et qu'il
était bon de pouvoir dévier la
circulation de transit sur un nouvel axe
de circulation qui est la départementale
121 et d'autres projets sont en cours
comme sur la rd 154 avec le
contournement de verneuil-sur-seine et
vernouillet toujours dans le cadre de
ses compétences telles que définies par
la nouvelle organisation territoriale de
2015 le département intervient également
pour développer les transports en commun
avec la création d'une voie de bus
spécifique lors du doublement du pont
schuller à la verrière il ne faut pas
oublier le transport ferroviaire
plusieurs dossiers importants sont en
cours en partenariat avec l'état et la
région
la ligne 18 du métro automatique du
grand paris express est aussi le
prolongement du rer e à l'ouest c'est au
tour de table
on ne participe pas des travaux ne
peuvent pas se réaliser
je pense à eole
concerne la vallée de seine
mais je pense aussi aux trams 13 qui va
relier un jour versailles mais
commençons par saint cyr l'école jusqu'à
saint germain en laye et qui se
poursuivra jusqu à poissy et les enjeux
sont importants car le cadre de vie des
habitants et l'attractivité du
territoire sont en jeu une entreprise
viendra sur un territoire qui est
attractif
donc il faut qu'il ait le foncier et il
faut qu'il ait les organes
d'infrastructures qui lui permettent de
faire venir ses salariés de pouvoir
faire venir ses fournisseurs et de
pouvoir livrer dans de bonnes conditions
sa production on notera que le
département a lancé en 2018 un
observatoire de la mobilité afin de
mesurer au mieux les besoins
il a révélé l'an dernier que les
yvelinois se déplacer en moyenne plus
que les autres franciliens et que 54 %
de ces déplacements se faisaient en
voiture contre 38 % à l'échelle
régionale